et maintenant les diapos sherritt à pomy
l'écran mais si on regarde ce qui est
tout bon qu'il est ou bien bikélé tout
l'art regarde ta pas autre chose que de
l'écossais non on tape des draps
sentissi toute façon bas non moi je
trouve ça joli c'est sympa mais c'est
bien aller éteins la lumière pic alors
vous allez voir timothée où il est
timide je suis là je suis là rallume
il bouge pas mal et d'un je suis
toujours là clip klopp a alors là c'est
orly sud est la dame pipi et de dos et
moi je lui donne une première là combien
c'était un franc à france 5 en êtes
généreux dans ces cas là moi je me tiens
j'y vais pas moi je fais toujours pipier
la maison pas semblé de crise ça vous
plaît oui on voit bien le voyage
lasteyrie les clubs à ben alors là c'est
pendant le vol
ah oui alors ça c'est la mer de nuages
là non c'est mon ses sherpas ah oui là
on avait un oeuf un oeuf dur alors un
oeuf dur sur le plat
c'est soi ne fond plat ou à neuf figures
c'est dans l'avion c'est maintenant
c'est un oeuf dur qui était sur le plan
d'accord ok j'ai combien puis alors à
côté on avait une barquette avec des
carottes voit les râper rap est d'accord
thérapie et à côté il y avait un autre
compartiment alors avec la moutarde le
poids est celle depuis alors on a repris
deux fois du vin avec jeanine et on voit
leurs deux gobelets il était vite on les
voit très très mal vers l'immeuble est
vide
s'il vous plaît ah oui les côtés du
aulas et les carottes
oui et non c'est non non c'est bien les
plats va alors là c'est nos bagages à la
sortie de l'est vraiment d'accord et dit
forget là vous voyez la valise au
premier plan ah oui oui oui il ya 1,5 en
cuir à côté à côté et ben derrière on
aperçoit notre valise c'est ça
alors sur la gauche annonce sur la
droite non mais derrière c'est sur la
bouche nom d'allah bleu sur la droite
alors c'est là s'est levé à verte
non c'est la bleue à droite c'est la
bleue timothée d'accord c'est la
blessure de peshawar faisant mes excuses
et le mais il s'énerve un peu ça c'est
quand il a faim à peu près tout à l'air
tout à l'heure on a des quelques
d'accord click clap problème ici là
c'est la plage
je reconnais les manier sur la droite
il ya beaucoup de voitures sur cette
plage je sais mieux à hasnon rose et je
vois la voiture c'est l'état a laissé là
l'endroit parce que j'ai le sentiment de
la tête là c'est le parquet est jolie
comme parti ça vos partys et clope au
projet ses toiles
ça c'est toi je te reconnais qu'au top
alors là j'étais en réanimation là
j'avais plongé dans un endroit où il y
avait pas d'eau tu t mac à la patinoire
alors là c'est la mer à bâle à ouidah
c'est le marchand de glaces sur la plage
elle est pas bien cadré à on voit juste
la tête un joli à huy en arriver à temps
on connaît bien les deux boules à roger
là elle s'était parfumé à la vanille
fraise
je ne savais ni dieu ni café j'ai dit ça
tu peut rallumer
pour elle c'est m je suis toujours ça
vous a plu
non c'est pas juste oui oui oui c'est
bien l'avouer c'est oui si on voit bien
le voyage en fin de mais bon vu
d'ailleurs si on leur faisait une petite
surprise
oui oui attendez attendez rester oui on
a les matins vous avez visité la salle
de bain tout à l'heure oui mais
29 ébranlé on a les photos d'avant les
travaux